let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
is the number we've got a caller from a
16-0 area code who sounds like they're
in a very very loud place caller in 6 1
0 what's your name where you're calling
from it's on your mind today
hey Dave it's the Dragonborn again
what's going on what can we do for you I
just want to get your opinion on the old
Jimmy Kimmel sing in the response to
people like Mark Davis and Ben Shapiro
there were kind of like you know saying
oh look at this comedian trying to
politicize dying kids or something like
that what your thought on that
what's my thoughts specifically on what
I mean I know Jimmy Kimmel has done
another sort of appeal to common decency
and saying hey let's not do something
that will take away health insurance
from 32 million people but what
specifically are you asking me about
dragon the response of conservatives on
Jimmy Kimmel politicizing it again like
if you go to bunch of Heroes Twitter and
mark dice is Twitter yeah they're kind
of loosening it up a bit there yeah
listen I don't really care what Ben
Shapiro and Mark dice have to say about
Jimmy Kimmel politicizing health care
the problem is that what makes health
care political is that health care
industries health care ensure the health
care industry has lobbyists the health
care industry has a profit motive and
that's what makes it political I agree
let's not politicize health care but
let's not politicize it by taking care
of people the way other OECD developed
countries do then you wouldn't have mark
Dyson Benz to ben shapiro by the way
both of them I know politicizing it all
right dragon it sounds like you're in
some kind of romper room or something so
I'm gonna let you go it sounds crazy I
hope you're safe because it sounds it's
either a really fun environment
Dragonborn is in or an incredibly
dangerous one I don't know why print out
with Dragonborn never never know where
he is